Guten Abend, mein Name ist Derya S.
Ich bin der Arzt der Arzt auf dieser Station.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Birgit Schumacher.
Birgit Schumacher.
Könnten Sie bitte mit der Ehren voll und nach Namen langsam stabieren?
Ja, Birgit schreibt sich B-I-R-G-I-T.
Birgit Schumacher schreibt sich S-C-H-U-H-M-A-C-H-E-R.
Schumacher.
Frau Schumacher.
Wie abtet ihr?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
18 Jahre alt.
Am 15. Februar 1966.
Frau Schumacher, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Seit ungefähr zwei Stunden begann das,
dass mir plötzlich unwohl sei, war übel.
Ich habe auch zweimal erbrochen.
Ich habe so ein Druckgefühl im Brustkorbbereich und auch im Oberbauch.
Ich habe auch etwas schwindel.
Ich bekomme nicht so gut Luft.
Es tut auch etwas weh, aber es ist ein Druck.
Wo genau tut es weh?
Sie haben schon den Brustkorb, aber in der Mitte.
Als ob der Brustkorb zusammengedrückt wird,
ob sich jemand um den Brustkorb legt und zusammenpresst.
Hinter den Brustbeinen und unter den Brustbeinen im Oberbauch.
Da habe ich auch diesen Druck.
Haben Sie gerade Atemnot?
Ja, ich habe auch etwas Luftnot.
Strahlen die Schmerzen in einer anderen körperlichen Teil aus?
Nein, nicht so richtig.
Ich meine in den linken Arm oder in den Haarys Unterkiffer.
Vielleicht etwas hier oben hin, aber das ist nicht so viel.
Hauptsächlich ist das hier im Brustkorbbereich.
Ich verstehe das.
Ist Ihnen ein Endegefühl aufgefallen?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann nicht richtig durchatmen.
Deswegen habe ich eben auch etwas Luftnot.
Frau Schumann, ich möchte unser Gespräch kurz unterbrechen.
Sollte ich Ihre Mithaltszeichen überprüfen.
Wenn alles in Ordnung ist, dann werden wir unser Gespräch weiter machen.
Das können wir machen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Überleichtheit haben und 2 Mal Erbruch.
Wie sieht das Erbruch aus?
Ja, das ist, glaube ich, weil ich vorher gerade gefrühstückt habe.
Das ist eine Scheibe Toast gewesen mit etwas Marmelade und Käse, glaube ich so.
Das war ziemlich frisch erbrochen.
Frisch erbrochen.
Ist Ihnen Blut im Erbruch aufgefallen?
Ich habe nicht gesehen.
Haben Sie eine körperliche oder emotionale Belastung bemerkt?
Vorher? Nein, das war direkt so, als ich gefrühstückt habe.
Da wollte ich gerade Zeitung lesen und da fing das an.
Ich habe mich vorher nicht irgendwie belastet gefühlt oder etwas Anstrengendes gemacht.
Das habe ich gar nicht gemacht.
Haben Sie dagegen Ihre Persche mit Kamenten eingenommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich bin gleich jetzt zu Ihnen gekommen.
Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung geblieben, Frau Schumer.
Gibt es etwas, das dich Marston Lindart oder versteckt?
Ich darf mich nicht groß bewegen, weil dann kriege ich mehr Luftnot.
Ich bleibe lieber ganz ruhig sitzen.
Das ist noch am besten.
Bewegelung ist nicht gut.
Frau Schumer, gibt es...
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala,
wobei ein sehr leites Schmerz und ein sehr starkes Schmerz entsteht?
Ich würde sagen dieser Schmerz ist der Druck vielleicht 4 bis 5.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie auch Oberbauschmerzen...
Sie haben genau, wo genau tut er im Oberbau?
Nein, direkt unter dem Brustbein, wo dieser Musken ist, der sich so etwas bewegt.
Da ist das in der Mitte.
Aber ich glaube, das hängt irgendwie so zusammen.
Ist Ihnen Herzstraßen, Herzklopern, Herzstoppern aufgefallen?
Nein, ist mir bisher nicht aufgefallen.
Habe ich allerdings auch nichts drauf geachtet.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerde?
Nein, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe beobachtet, wie ich wohne im zweiten Stockwerk,
in meiner Wohnung, dass manchmal in letzter Zeit,
wenn ich dann noch etwas eingekauft habe, eine Einkaufstasche hatte,
früher hatte ich keine Probleme, da bin ich immer die zwei Stockwerke hoch gelaufen.
Letzter Zeit habe ich dann mal auch schon mal angehalten und gestoppt,
pausiert im ersten Stock und dann ging es nach einigen Sekunden wieder weiter.
Also es wurde mir so ein bisschen die Luft zu eng.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich viel wie?
Nein, nein.
Ist Ihnen ein Schweißausbruch ausgefallen?
Im Anfang, als der Schmerz losging, da habe ich glaube ich geschwitzt so,
aber jetzt im Augenblick geht das wieder.
Aber am Anfang hatte ich so einen Schweißausbruch.
Ich war auch sehr erschrocken, als das losging, weil ich so etwas kenne ich nicht.
Ja, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlösen oder Stuber?
Nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Hat Ihre Beschwerde im Verlauf verändert?
Ich meine, haben die Beschwerden verbessert oder verschrieben?
Ja, sie sind eher ein bisschen schlimmer geworden.
Hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert?
Haben Sie ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Ich habe mein Gewicht seit, weiß ich nicht, 10 Jahren oder so gehalten.
Wie viel wiegt Sie so Zeit?
64 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Schlafen Sie gut, Frau Schumacher?
Ja, ich kann gut schlafen.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Auch mein Appetit ist gut.
Ich esse nicht alles, versuche Gemüse zu essen mehrfach in der Woche
und nicht so viel Fleisch.
Aber ich esse auch mal ganz gerne, was Süßes,
obwohl der Erz sagt mir, weil mein Cholesterin zu hoch ist,
da nehme ich auch eine Tablette ein, da muss ich alles auf etwas aufpassen.
Auch fetter Käse, da muss ich aufpassen.
Aber der schmeckt manchmal sehr gut.
Ich halte mein Gewicht.
Haben Sie Husten?
Ja, ich habe so ein bisschen Husten, weil ich auch auch.
Da muss ich hin und wieder schon Husten.
Gerade morgens muss ich häufig abhusten, dann kommt dann auch ein bisschen Schleim raus.
Das kenne ich aber schon seit einigen Jahren.
Einigen Jahre.
Wie sieht der Auswurf aus?
Das ist so.
Geldlich schleim ich manchmal oder hell schleim ich, aber nicht irgendwie dunkel oder so.
Der Auswurf ist nur am morgens bestehen.
Ja, morgens habe ich das so, nach dem Aufstehen.
Da muss ich dann längere Zeit Husten und da kommt dann auch Schleim raus
und nachher wird das wieder besser.
Der besser.
Frau Schumacher, sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Vorherkanzen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass sie erhöhte Bluthoch werkt.
Ich habe hohe, höhere Cholesterinwert.
Seit einigen Jahren, und da nehme ich seit fünf Jahren eine Tablette
und habe dann noch, nehme eine Tablette auch für die Schilddrüse,
weil meine Schilddrüse ist vergrößert
und in der rechten Schilddrüse ist ein Knoten
und das soll jetzt noch beobachtet werden.
Wenn das jetzt aber nicht kleiner wird unter der Behandlung alles,
dann muss das operiert werden.
Ja.
Hab ich richtig verstanden, wo denn Sie wegen Schilddrüse operiert?
Noch nicht.
Aber es kann sein, wenn das nicht besser wird,
dann muss es operiert werden.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Probleme?
Auch bekannt ist das mindestens schon zehn Jahre.
Gebt es noch andere Krankheiten, Bluthochdruck oder Zuckerkrankheit?
Nein, das ist nicht bekannt.
Nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, für Cholesterin nehme ich einen Mittelpunkt,
der heißt Rosovastatin.
Rosovastatin.
Rosovastatin, ja.
Dahinter steht 20,
eine Tablette, morgens.
Eine Tablette, morgens.
Und dann nehme ich noch für die Schilddrüse L-Tyroxin,
dahinter steht 50,
dann nehme ich auch eine morgens.
Eine morgens.
Gibt es noch andere?
Ja, aber was mir noch einfällt, ich habe Heuschnupfen,
so im Frühjahr, ganz früh im Frühjahr, Hasel, Erle, Weide,
da bin ich allergisch ein bisschen drauf.
Da kriege ich dann Niesreiz und Jucken in der Nase und so.
Aber das ist nur wenige Wochen,
und da habe ich inzwischen, suche ich das zu vermeiden,
indem ich da nicht in diese Gegend gehe, wo das wächst.
Aber im Sommer sonst habe ich keine Probleme mit Heuschnupfen,
das ist nur im Februar, Februar, März, da ist das.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Kommentare?
Nein, nehme ich nicht.
Frau, Sie sind bei Ihnen allergisch bekannt?
Ja, nur diese Heuschnupfen mit diesem Frühblüren Hasel,
sonst habe ich keine Allergien, nein.
Wie lern Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind wurde ich am Blindarm operiert, da war ich 10 Jahre alt,
und dann wurde ich nochmal mit 12 Jahren an den Mandeln operiert.
Gibt es noch eine Operation?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie rauchern.
Wie viel und wie oft rauchen Sie?
Ja, ich rauch schon ziemlich lange, ich bin jetzt 58, seit 37 Jahren rauch ich.
37?
Und jeden Tag eine Schachtel.
Zigaretten?
Ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber nicht so viel, ich trink vielleicht innerhalb einer Woche so 2 Glas Wein.
Also nicht jeden Tag.
2 Glas Wein.
Seit wann trinken Sie?
Auch so, 25, 30 Jahre vielleicht.
35.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie keine Drogen nehmen, oder?
Nein, Drogen nehme ich nicht.
Frau Schumacher, sind Sie gegen Corona Hepatitis oder Kinderkrankheit geimpft?
Ja, ich war letztens gerade noch bei meiner Hausärztin, die hat den Impfvers angeschaut
und hat gesagt, das ist soweit alles erst mal gut.
Ich soll mich diesen Herbst jetzt wieder gegen Corona impfen lassen,
das habe ich bisher aber noch nicht gemacht, aber das wollte ich jetzt in den nächsten Wochen machen.
Ja.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Haus da gewiesen?
Ja, ich war in Griechenland eine Woche auf Kreta, das war im Frühsommer,
aber sonst habe ich keine Auslandsreise gemacht in letzter Zeit.
Im Sommer, ja.
Frau Schumacher, haben Ihre Eltern irgendwelche Erplankungen?
Ja, der Vater, der ist mit 68 Jahren im Alter von 68 Jahren an einem Herzinfarkt verstorben.
Mein Mann?
Ja, die Mutter, die ist 82 Jahre alt, die lebt noch, die hat Alterszucker und hohen Blutdruck
und dann habe ich einen Bruder, 59 Jahre alt, der hatte vor einem Jahr
eine Beipass-Operation am Herzen, weil der zu einer Herz-Granzgefäße hatte
und da hatte er eine Beipass-Operation bekommen.
Okay, verstehe.
Frau Schumacher, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet, wir haben zwei Kinder, die sind 32 und 29, die sind aber gesund.
Neune?
29 und 30.
Gesund, ja.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin Friseurin.
Ich möchte zu Ihrer Akzene Beschwärtern zurückkommen.
Ist die Ihnen geschwollene Bein oder Krampfader aufgefallen?
Nein, ist nicht. Die Beine sind immer ziemlich schlank.
Die sind noch nie geschwollengewesen und Krampfadern glaube ich habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Schumacher, ich habe für mich alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Aber Sie fragen oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, was kann das sein?
So etwas macht mir jetzt doch Sorge, weil ich so etwas habe ich ja noch nie gehabt.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Sorge, Frau Schumacher.
Aber es ist so etwas zu genau sagen.
Aber ich vermute eine Herzkrankheit oder Schlagadeprobleme.
Okay.
Oder eine Lungenprobleme.
Aber zuerst muss ich die Körper untersuchen.
Ich brauche auch Blutunterzuhungen.
Wir brauchen auch Wildgebende unterzuholen.
Sobald alle Ergebnisse vorliegen, werden wir das weitere vorgehen.
Okay, so können wir das machen.
Gut.
Dann würde ich jetzt sagen, haben Sie mal 10 Minuten, sagen wir mal bis gut halb sieben.
Und Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben, haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Oder ist etwas nicht verstanden worden?
Haben wir etwas vergessen?
Sind Sie schon wechseljahre?
Ja, die Periode ist nicht mehr regelmäßig.
Ich bin auch bei der Frauenärztin regelmäßig.
Die sagt aber, das ist jetzt mein Klimakterium.
Und es geht mir ganz gut damit.
Ist Ihre Schmerzen, Atem oder Bewegung abhängig?
Nein, sicher nicht.
Wenn ich mich bewege, dann kriege ich nur schlechter Luft.
Aber unter Atem abhängig, glaube ich auch nicht.
Aber ich habe das Gefühl, ich kann eben nicht richtig atmen,
weil das so drückt auf der Brust.
Wann war Ihr letztes Haus als Besuch und wurden die Kontrolle gemacht?
Zum Beispiel Alta-Zuka oder Arterele Bartoni?
Das war jetzt auch im Frühsommer.
Aber da war nichts Auffälliges.
Mein Blutdruck ist immer so an der Grenze, sagt die Hausärztin.
Aber im Augenblick muss man da wohl noch nichts machen.
Ich habe noch nicht mehr Medikament oder so.
Und die Kollesterolin war mit der Tablette viel besser geworden.
Der Wert noch nicht optimal.
Ich soll mich weiterhin auch mit der Ernährung ein bisschen aufpassen.
Aber sonst war das so weit zufriedenstellend.
Verstanden, danke.
Frau Schumacher, habe ich eine Frage?
Ja.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Nein, ich treibe überhaupt keinen Sport.
Aber machten Sie auch Ihre Ernährung?
Ja, schon etwas.
Ich habe das vorhin mal gesagt.
Ich versuche nur ein bis zweimal pro Woche Fleisch zu essen.
Auch Gemüse.
Aber manchmal esse ich auch gerne etwas Süßes.
Jetzt gerade auch wieder in der Weihnachtszeit.
Da gibt es so viele Süßigkeiten.
Haben Sie Internet-Sterse, Gewichtsabnahme?
Nein, mein Gewicht habe ich gehalten.
Wie viele Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Wie viele Kissen?
Nur zwei dünne Kissen.
Ich kann relativ gut flach liegen.
Haben Sie geschwollene Gerötete im Bein bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Meine Beine sind sehr schlank.
Und die waren eigentlich noch nie irgendwie dick oder geschwollen.
Haben Sie Schluckbeschwerden oder Heisekeit bemerkt?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Haben Sie Ihre Vorsorgeunterzungen gemacht lassen?
Damkrebs oder Gebärmbehauskrebs?
Damkrebs habe ich bisher noch nicht gemacht.
Ich wollte das jetzt demnächst machen.
Meine Hausärztin hat das beraten,
dass das auf alle Fälle jetzt nach Weihnachten
oder im neuen Jahr mal gemacht wird.
Auch die Frauenärztin hat dazu geraten.
Bei der Hautkrebsvorsorge war ich bisher noch nicht.
Okay, danke.
Sie haben gesagt, es gab ein Druck zu sein.
Wie viele Minuten hat die Druck gedauert?
Heute morgen jetzt, als das anfing?
Ja, ja.
Den Druck habe ich jetzt immer noch.
Es ist immer noch so ein Druck in der Brust.
Das ist seit zwei Stunden jetzt.
Haben Sie Sotbrennen?
Sotbrennen?
Nein, Sotbrennen habe ich nicht.
So etwas kenne ich gar nicht.
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ja, wenn jetzt erstmal die Fragen so weit gestellt sind,
wir geben dem Kollegen vielleicht noch einige Minuten Zeit.
Ich komme gleich sofort wieder, sagen wir in vier Minuten.
Und dann können wir dann ja mit der Vorstellung beginnen.
Ich komme gleich wieder.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberart.
Ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Wir gehen schon mal, ist eine 48-jährige Patientin.
Sie kam zu uns mit vor zwei Stunden aufgetretenen bestehenden
rätristinalen Torachschmerzen und epigastralen abdominal Schmerzen
ohne Ausstrahlung.
Die Patientin klappt über Dyspnoe und Endigkehfüll.
Die Schmerzintestät liegen bei vier bis fünf auf einer Schmerzskala.
Des Weiteren berichtet die Patientin, dass die Schmerzen sich
im Verlauf schlimmer geworden.
Und Ausserden erzählt die Patientin, dass die Schmerzen
bei der Bewegung verstebt sind.
Bei genauer Befragung berichtet die Patientin, dass sie morgens
produktiver Rüstung hat.
Die Vegetative an einem Nese.
Hat die Patientin Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Ja, der Patient klappt nause und zweimal vomitus.
Das Erbrochen sieht als Schweiß-Rest aus.
Die Vegetative an einem Nese ist bis auf Schweißausbrüche
unaufgänglich.
An der Vorerkrankung sind Hyperkolesteronemie und Strumma bekannt.
Die Patientin nimmt 20 mg ein Mal morgens und Erdruck 50 mg ein Mal morgens.
Ist es nur eine einfache Strumma?
Mit Knoten.
Ich konnte nicht erinnern.
Das hat schon im Chat geschrieben.
Strumma nodosa.
Nodulus der Knoten.
Die Patientin hat eine Strumma nodosa.
Haben Sie den Anfangs bei diesen Beschwerden die Vitalparameter kontrolliert?
Ja, ich habe die Parameter kontrolliert.
Ich habe einen EKG geschrieben.
War es eine erntfähige Auffälligkeit?
Es gibt keine.
Wichtig ist, dass Sie bei der Schilderung das ruhig sagen,
dass Sie gleich zu Anfang die Vitalparameter kontrolliert haben.
Es war ein Sinusrhythmus.
Vielleicht Frequenz 95.
SBO 2,92 oder 91.
Und noch ein Blutdruck, der bei 140,92 ist.
Also keine hochpathologischen oder auffälligen Werte.
Patientin ist in stabilen Kreislaufverhältnissen.
Die Patientin hat allergische Rheonitis.
Die allergienäusschürzig durch Neesen und Jücken.
Ist das eine ganzjährige allergische Rheonitis?
Nein, nur im Februar und März.
Auf Frühblüher.
Mit 10 Jahren würde eine Appendoktöne vorgenommen.
Mit 12 Jahren würde eine Tonselektronik vorgenommen.
Die Patientin ist eine Rauchherrin.
Sie raucht täglich Einpackung Sibaraten.
Seit 37 Jahren.
Sie können sagen, es besteht ein erheblicher Nikotin-Abusus.
Über 37 Packages.
37 Jahre lang eine Paket.
Sie trägt seit 35 Jahren ein Glas Wein in der Woche.
Und drückenkonsum wurde verneint.
Impfung, Status und Reiseanalyse ist unauffällig.
In der Familienanalyse hat ihr Vater mit 68 Jahren an Myocardinfarkt gestorben.
Der Vater ist mit 68 Jahren an einem Myocardinfarkt verstorben.
Die Mutter ist 82 Jahre alt.
Sie hat Diabetes mellitus II und Arteriolechpertoni.
Der Bruder ist 59 Jahre alt.
Er wurde bei ihm Beipass durchgeführt.
Ein Coronarebeipass.
Die Patientin hatte eine Erkrankung vor dem Ereignis.
Sie haben keine Beschwerde.
Die Patientin hat berichtet, dass sie in den letzten Wochen beim Treppen steigen.
Wenn sie in ihre Wohnung geht, hat die Patientin gesagt, wenn ich eine Einkaufstrasche getragen habe,
dann habe ich in letzter Zeit Luftnoten, enge Gefühle gehabt.
An amnestisch berichtet die Patientin über eine gewisse Belastungsdispnö.
Sie wohnt im zweiten Stockwerk in den letzten Wochen.
Aber keine Schmerzen.
Sie ist verheiratet und hat zwei gesünder Kinder.
Sie ist Frisörin.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Die
Okay, gut. Danke. Sicherlich müssen diese Verdachtstiagnosen, die sie genannt haben,
in Betracht gezogen werden und untersucht werden. Ich würde fast eher dazu tendieren,
dass diese Frau vielleicht doch ein akutes Coronasyndrom hat. Wir wissen gerade bei Frauen,
ist die Schmerzcharakteristik oft nicht so typisch, nicht der typische Armschmerz oder
typische Schmerz in den Rücken oder in die Kieferregion, unter der Kieferregion. Sie
hatte relativ akutes Ereignis gehabt. Sie hatte einige Wochen vorher schon mal zumindest
Bedastungsdispnö. Sie ist, was vielleicht ihre Gesundheit angeht, nicht so ganz
gewissenhaft hinterher. Bitte beobachtet sich vielleicht gar nicht so gut. Also vielleicht
Verdachtstiagnose, akutes Coronasyndrom, Lungenemboliede, differenzial diagnostisch
Erordn, Distektion, Ulkos. Diese Dinge kommen sicherlich auch mit in Betracht. Wichtig ist,
dass sie gleich zu Anfang die Vita-Parameter kontrolliert haben, um da erst mal sicher zu
sein, dass es jetzt nichts Intensivpflichtiges ist oder wo wir sofort intervenieren müssen.
Aber der Verlauf kann natürlich zu einem Hinweis eines akuten Coronasyndroms führen. Die
Labordiagnostik vielleicht kann das hinweisen und ein erneutes EKG natürlich auch.
EKG muss ja so früh noch nicht unbedingt gleich etwas nachweisbar sein. Das kann ja auch später
kommen. Aber auf alle Fälle muss die Patientin überwacht werden. Man darf sie jetzt nicht
irgendwo aus den Augen lassen und sagen, in drei, vier Stunden machen wir jetzt die nächste
Untersuchung, sondern das muss jetzt gut überwacht sein und sie muss ein Monitoring
bekommen, um da keine Komplikation zu bemerken, die vielleicht auftreten können.
Gut, vielen Dank. Das haben sie, finde ich, sehr gut gemacht. Sie haben das sehr ruhig
gemacht und auch systematisch die Anamnese erhoben und konnten dann auch in der Schilderung
die, denke ich, wesentlichen fachmedizinischen Ausdrücke auch das gut übersetzen. Und das fand
ich sehr gut. Denken Sie einfach nur mal dran, wo ich am Anfang zu sagen, ich habe gleich zu
Anfang aufgrund der Symptomatik die Vitalparameter kontrolliert. Die Patientin befand sich in einem
stabilen Kreislaufzustand und im EKG waren zunächst keine Auffälligkeiten, sodass sie dann die
Anamneseerhebung fortsetzen konnten zunächst. Was man vielleicht noch hätte machen können,
wenn die natürlich den Verdacht vielleicht auf ein Coronasyndrom haben, der Blutdruck war
eine Ermaßen, dass die der Patientin probatorisch die Trolinge Wargspray geben, wenn sie in die
Richtung eines akuten Coronasyndroms denken. Das kann man ja durchaus probieren und die Patientin
nach ein paar Minuten zu befragen. Ich habe ihn etwas in den Mund gesprüht, haben sie irgendein
etwas bemerkt, Wirkung. Im schützten Fall kann die Patientin sagen, ich habe den Eindruck,
es ist etwas besser geworden auf meiner Brust. Ja, das kann ja durchaus mal sein. Und bei
einem Blutdruck von 140 zu 90 können sie das gut machen. Wenn er nun sehr viel niedriger ist,
dann muss man sich das überlegen. Aber damit passiert ja nichts. Ja, erst mal vielen Dank und
Sie haben, denke ich, alles gebracht mit der Familienanamnese und die Geschwister. Sie haben
die Zahlen auch gut wiederholt, also richtig wiederholt, was ja nicht immer so einfach ist,
aber das haben Sie alles korrekt gemacht. Und ich würde sagen, machen Sie bald die Prüfung.
Ja, mein Prüfung im 13. Januar. Ja, das ist doch nicht mehr so lange. Hab ich ein gutes Gefühl. Wo
machen Sie die Prüfung? Welche Ärztekammer? In Stuttgart. Okay, gut, dann würde ich sagen,
verbringen Sie alle noch einen schönen Abend und...